good morning my name is James Perry and
I'm the head of the division of
neurology here at Sunnybrook Hospital I
want to thank you for your attention and
your concern in light of the difficult
news that you all received this morning
I'm a neuro-oncologist so I'm a
neurologist that specializes in the
treatment of brain tumors I work at the
adead Cancer Center here at Sunnybrook
Health Science Center the Odette Cancer
Centre is the sixth largest
comprehensive cancer center in North
America you probably aren't aware but 27
Canadians are diagnosed every day with a
brain tumor it's more than one an hour
for most of these Canadians the news is
relatively good because the tumor can be
removed almost in its entirety or least
in part and can be treated with
subsequent therapies and people can live
normal lives
afterwards unfortunately though even
some of these so-called benign brain
tumors can have devastating effects on
patients
Gort situation is different or it has a
primary brain tumor this is one that
started from within the brain itself
it's not cancer that has spread from
another part of the body and these
primary brain tumors are infiltrative by
Nature
so they're impossible to remove
completely by surgery they frequently
recur and they require other therapies
such as radiation and chemotherapy
treatment they range and how aggressive
they are from some that are fairly slow
growing to others that are very
aggressive and incurable
it's my difficult duty today to tell you
the core Downy's brain tumor is
incurable
he is a one of the most aggressive forms
of brain cancer called a glioblastoma or
a GBM for short and it's one of the most
common causes of cancer death in
Canadians between the ages of 40 and 60
years old at the Odette Cancer Centre we
treat 250 people a year with the same
tumor as ward and I've been doing it for
over
years at the center usually adults come
to attention because of focal
neurological symptoms depending where
the tumor is in the brain sometimes
these are seizures sometimes these are
neurological deficits like paralysis or
weakness and sometimes they can even be
stroke like in their nature Gort
developed his first symptoms in December
of 2015 the first step in managing these
beyond getting pictures like MRI scans
of the brain is an operation and at
Sunnybrook were very grateful to dr.
Douglas Cook in Kingston better known as
DJ Cooke who is a friend of the band and
an excellent neurosurgeon and then he
performed her at gourds board surgery
and excised the bulk of the brain tumor
after comprehensive examination of the
tissue with advanced scientific
techniques our team assembled here at
the Odette Cancer Centre to discuss the
most optimal treatment plan for Gord we
do this for every one of our new
patients as part of a multidisciplinary
case conference board was given
radiation treatment for 6 weeks this
consists of 30 treatments daily from
Monday to Friday for six weeks combined
with chemotherapy medication he
completed that treatment a little more
than a month ago the most debilitating
aspect of that treatment is fatigue and
he was tired some would say he was tired
as you know what and he has improved
since fortunately for Gord he has a type
of glioblastoma that is more amenable to
treatment than most through research we
have learned of certain biomarkers or
proteins on the surface of tumors that
are associated with a more favorable
response to treatment and also confer a
significantly higher chance of longer
term survival and Gauri has one of these
proteins
I want to acknowledge my colleague dr.
Arjun sagal who is the head of our tumor
group at the Odette Cancer Centre and
who gave Gord his radiation treatment
Gords now continuing with ongoing
chemotherapy in the form of maintenance
chemotherapy and in the last several
weeks has rallied tremendously in fact
last week he had a very important MRI
scan of the brain that showed that all
of the swelling in his head in the left
temporal lobe area has decreased
substantially and the amount of tumor
that we see residual has clearly shrunk
and he's doing very well I was made
aware for a series of conversations with
board and the band and his management
team that they had plans to tour this
summer
all of my patients of course have
trepidation about returning to their
jobs returning to their daily lives
wondering what the future holds but you
can imagine what the unique position I
was in to give advice to one of the most
iconic individuals in the country and a
task such as a tour across the country I
was quickly impressed by Gords
resilience and courage to stay ahead of
the news and this is why the news
release came out today for many people
in fact for most of my patients it's
daunting to actually reveal your
diagnosis not only to family how do I
tell my my kids how do I deal with this
with my co-workers let alone somebody
that is truly a national treasure the
news today while sad also creates for us
in brain tumor research an unprecedented
opportunity to create awareness and to
create an opportunity for fundraising
for research that's desperately needed
to improve the odds for all people with
this disease for its courage and coming
forward with his diagnosis will be a
beacon for all patients with
glioblastoma in Canada they will see a
survivor continuing with this craft
despite its many challenges the
University of Toronto
is amongst the world's greatest centres
of excellence for brain tumor research
and we're committed and are leading in
the quest for better therapies and
improved quality of life and long-term
survival for patients like board
although the future can never be
predicted with certainty our team and I
are confident that Gordon the band will
dig deep and we'll complete the tour and
I don't anticipate any medical issues in
the short term that would prevent the
band from continuing with the tour plans
which will be shortly announced beyond
today's medical update there are no
plans for ongoing medical communication
about cords condition if you request
that we respect his privacy and allow
the band and their music to do the
talking with that I'll sit down and take
questions
right so it's unfortunately not a
curable tumor either other people have
been other notable people have had this
tumor recently Ted Kennedy Joe Biden's
son
so unfortunately even with the greatest
connections and and money
there's no way to buy your way out of
this it's too early right now in board's
trajectory to understand what his
prognosis might be because when it comes
down to individuals we only have
statistics and statistics just don't
tell the picture
yeah so I'm not I'm not trying to avoid
the question it's it's just too early
because there's a very wide spectrum of
prognosis in this disease so pancreatic
cancer is very different although you'll
see there are long term survivors of
pancreatic cancer but that's not what
we're here to talk about today the the
ultimate thing was was a seizure and
that seizure led to an emergency room
visit that discarded that led to imaging
that showed a tumor
so Fortin fortunately it was in the
location of the brain that was operable
it wasn't large tumor and dr. cook in
Kingston was able to remove the majority
of it yes so this is um this is
something that the medical team at
Sunnybrook and the band's management
team have had many months I think you
are hearing the news today but we've
obviously known about this and
anticipated this for quite some time so
his treatment has had that in mind we
will have medical contingencies
available for any unexpected medical
emergencies or problems that come up I
don't anticipate that there will be any
though he's doing very well
they've started rehearsing I was lucky
enough to see a few of those and they're
very good
is there any yeah so the left temporal
lobe of the brain in most people is
dominant for memory especially
short-term memory and for language
function one of the interesting things
about memory is that there are different
sorts of memory
so there's lyrical memory we all
remember the words to happy birthday
without having to think about it and for
a professional musician remembering the
words to songs that have been written by
yourself and sung thousands of times
would not produce a problem that I can
anticipate in that regard
I said I said in my my statement and
just again that it's in the left
temporal lobe of the brain so on the
left side in in the area near where
speech and memory are no I can't I can't
save Nassau I imagine the same reaction
that's happening everywhere today really
you know this is sure in general with
with this type of tumor that's our
primary role obviously not you know
patient care comes first but research is
what we do we're academic physicians
Sunnybrook happens to be the national
headquarters for the Canadian brain
tumor consortium which is our national
network for clinical trials testing
experimental therapy there are several
ongoing clinical trials currently at our
Cancer Center and others all throughout
the country they involve things from
implantation of virus into the tumor
cavity things like intravenously
delivered gene therapy which might be
what you're referring to which is which
is an Israeli company and new forms of
chemo therapies so there's a tremendous
amount of hope and part of part of our
job is to try to get our patients you
know push down field long enough so the
research can catch up with them
no gourd has been given the same
treatment you know we have thanks to
research about ten years ago a clear
standard of care treatment that's given
throughout North America and Europe
because of his type of tumour he's
responded to it in a very positive way
so his symptoms improved and he's doing
quite well so there's been nothing
different in that regard